the laws of the universe since Newton at
least people like Newton scientists most
of us have assumed the universe is
governed by unchanging laws even if God
didn't put them down they were there but
are the laws that we think of as
universal and unchanging are they if
they are how do they emerge where do
they live how do they have their effect
or are they are we mistaken are they not
universal laws not written in stone
somewhere are they just human constructs
that are going to remain unknowable and
inexplicable and we're just sort of
approximating on my right
Helen Beebe Manchester professor of
philosophy I never get Nobel
prize-winning physicist and left his
left Laura Mercier Houghton cosmologists
professor of physics which was trying to
discover how this universe might
actually have come into being she
stumbled upon the multiverse and has
caused confusion ever since are the laws
eternal features of this universe
obviously one distinctive feature of
laws is they seem to be universal or at
least they're very general sorts of
things that's not just true in
astrophysics or quantum mechanics it's
true in chemistry and biology choose at
least some extent even in things like
psychology and the social sciences so at
least one thing that laws do is somehow
encode deep and pervasive regularities
in the universe but for me from a
metaphysical point of view because I am
a meta physician the really interesting
and puzzling question is this are they
just a way of encoding those
regularities are they just generally
generalizations that we formulate that
happen to apply you know always and
everywhere or are they somehow things
that lie behind those regularities
things that make the universe unfold in
this orderly and regular way that it
does so in the word law is really
suggestive right when we talk about laws
of nature so when we talk about the laws
of the land right don't steal people's
stuff don't go around
people don't commit perjury and so on
obviously those laws aren't just ways of
encoding regularities I mean for one
thing they're not even regularities
because people break the law all the
time as we know but more importantly
those sorts of laws are prescriptive
things right there things that we obey
or not as the case may be
so the wards law as applied to the laws
of nature kind of suggests that they're
prescriptive as well there's somehow
rules that everything abides by but now
here's the mystery how on earth could
that happen right that's a really
strange thing so we know how we obey
laws you know what the rules are and you
kind of obey them consciously and
deliberately so you see the speed limits
and you look at your speedometer and you
if you if you're minded to obey the
traffic laws you put your foot on the
brake if you're going a bit too fast
that's definitely not what's going on
when you drop your cup of coffee and it
falls to the ground or when subatomic
particles or cannonballs or whatever
they are obey the laws of physics they
don't have minds they don't know what
the laws are they can't decide to do
what the laws say or not
so me and I'm kind of a human so I don't
like sort of deep deeply puzzling
metaphysical features of reality um I
find the idea that laws of nature of
prescriptive kind of completely
mysterious the idea that there are bayed
that they're things that govern what
happens in the universe because I just
can't see a way of making really good
sense of that idea so me I'm inclined to
think that the laws just are ways of
encoding the regularities and that's all
they are so to get back to the question
which was are the laws eternal features
at the universe or might they be human
constructs
well encoding the regularities is
something that we do not me personally
InDinero do so in some sense yes they
are human constructs but the
regularities that we're encoding they're
not human constructs they're out there
independently of us so in a sense no
they're not human constructs so in
classic philosophers style my answer to
the question is yes and
you see I thought you thought I was just
being funny okay clear law would be
something that cannot be disobeyed like
if it gravity is a law this paper can't
just ever decide not to fall where the
regularity it just means that it could
decide not to it just up till now it
always has you have opened a massive can
of worms yes I think we should be modest
in claiming that we know how the laws of
nature work and this isn't that we're
very far away from that what we are
doing in practice is all we can do is we
make observations we do it as best as we
can
and then we write down the regularities
that we see explain much of that we find
all the all the peculiar features that
that we can attach to the object we see
to make them behave the way we see them
behaving such as a laws of gravity which
are massless laws that tell you the
things seem to attract each other
there's a cosmological constant that
somehow seems to make things repelled
away from each other and there are the
motherís laws of quantum mechanics where
in a previous discussion we discussed
where these laws are really iron but
they say the eye or whether they're only
our perception of what they say they are
and I believe the latter that models of
nature are very much the way we perceive
the laws of nature but that reality may
be a lot more complicated and not yet
within sight I think but all together
these things form the laws of universe
and are very important questions about
them for instance how big actually is
universe what are the boundary
conditions of the universe is there a
boundary con
at the universe or not the universe
split up in many other universes further
away even then the first things you can
see all these questions one can ask but
not so easily answer
unless you have a model so we are fond
of making models to use them all the
time but I claims that my claim is that
we are still very far from the tools
with our models we are just catching the
surface all the laws of nature and
there's also a question which is going
to be asked is how permanent artists are
these laws do they change at all
well there's one important thing to
remember if you think that laws of
nature depend on space and time also and
there was one important physicist
actually thought that that was Paul
Dirac beautiful theory where it says the
only way to explain why nature so
company it's a who gradually more and
more complicated but the laws of nature
during the Big Bang were very simple and
then they evolved and became and
generated large numbers just as a
function of time that you could believe
but if you believe such a thing then you
have to say how good the laws of nature
change if you go from place to place or
if you go for earlier to later times how
do most of nature evolve
well the only way to handle that is to
introduce a kind of field which I'd call
a scalar field that says if the field
has this value then the laws of nature
such as such that maybe one there may be
many of such fields but you're making
your life hell of a lot more complicated
than it already is without such fields
so the first thing we should assume as
humans is that the laws that we
deciphered so far must be constant until
further notice maybe you'll discover
that things change okay in that case
you'll have to modify our our
understanding loss but these
modifications will be very complicated
you have new fields and then we have to
ask what are the equations of those
fields once you have those equations of
Francis the scalar field then you're
back at square one then the total
combination laws of physics is again the
same everywhere and then again you can
ask is it really the same and you go on
for it like it's forever you never reach
an end point so my bet is the laws of
nature that we discovered so far will be
the end of the line there's no reason
assume that they depend on other fields
which depend on space and time again
because if you start that early you'll
never end so but this is a just a gut
feeling
I may be wrong and if I'm wrong I want
people to show that to me where I'm
wrong and where it is shown that
nature's more complicated than you
really think okay so there are laws but
our version are models of them maybe
still fire from the toes but there are
closer to it and anything else we know
about okay so Laura what do you think I
agree with what it said and we would
really don't it is a hard question and
and we don't understand enough about it
so whatever I say it's my thinking and
it's speculation more than anything but
in terms of the laws of nature making
reference for something eternal is
reference to time so I find that
difficult to follow because I think laws
of nature are fundamental independently
of space and time on an utterly
perplexing
[Music]